my main question is actually on
something you said a couple lectures ago
it was something along the lines of uh
family um sorry I'm like god that's the
history of your family kind of like the
sins of your family something like that
yeah you uh you're facing it all the
time
yeah what's uh how can you expand on
that more well there's this idea in the
Old Testament that your sins might be
visited unto your family seven
generations down seems kind of harsh but
you know when you're confronting maybe
your father's tyrannical yeah but you
know maybe his father beat the hell out
of him and maybe his father's father was
a vicious alcoholic and he just bloody
well don't know how far back that goes
and and that means also you don't
exactly know what you're dealing with
right to some degree you're dealing with
your father but only partly what you're
dealing with is the pathological
paternal spirit something like that and
it's better to think about that way
because it becomes an existential issue
at that point you know so you could say
that well the father has two components
and I mean this psychologically speaking
there's the Great Father that's
beneficial and protective that that that
organized this society and teaches you
how to speak and has produced all these
wonderful things and then there's the
tyrannical oppressive part of the Father
just like there's the terrible part of
Mother Nature that's destructive and the
benevolent part of Mother Nature that's
wonderful and productive and you're
stuck with that right you're stuck with
having to mediate between those opposing
forces just like you're stuck with the
adversarial part of yourself in the
heroic part of yourself and it's up to
you to set those things right otherwise
they propagate into the future and it
isn't it's a straightforward thing to
say how to set them right there's quite
a good movie about that
Oh Magnolia which I really love it's by
Paul Anderson if I remember correctly I
hope that's right it's a beautiful movie
and it's about this part of it's about
this kid whose father's really pushing
them to be a superstar at
at a quiz show right he's a genius kid
he and the kids studies this guy named
Charles fort you don't understand this
movie if you don't know this because you
got to know about Charles fort to
understand magnolias charles fort was
this weird old guy who got rich with an
inheritance when he was like 20 and
spent the rest of his life in libraries
looking up impossible things and
documenting them impossible things that
couldn't happen from a scientific
perspective that were well attested to
by multiple observers and he produced
this news paper called the 14 times
which still runs anyways in magnolia
magnolia begins with this guy who falls
out of a building and then is shot by a
woman who misses her husband with a
rifle as he falls and I think she's
she's charged with murder and the street
names have something to do with the
deaths and his fall and all of that
happened and then in the movie there's a
rain of frogs and there are rains of
frogs from time to time sometimes
they're frozen sometimes they're rains
of fish sometimes they're frozen it's
like what the hell how does that happen
it happens quite frequently as it turns
out there's a rain of frogs in the in
the movie Magnolia and this little kid
see what happened to him is that he's on
stage and he ends up peeing his pants
because of the pressure basically and
humiliates himself and then there's this
rain of frogs which he kind of takes as
a sign from God and then he goes to his
father even he's like eight years old
this kid and he says you have to stop
doing this to me and he's dead serious
about very careful not being you know
what would you call insubordinate
nothing like that he decides that that's
coming to an end right now and you have
to make those decisions in your family
because otherwise things propagate down
the generations right and every family
is rife with pathologies of one form or
another and you can learn from that and
refuse to push it forward and that's
part of I think what you do when you
when you when you shoulder your
existential burden because everyone is
the beneficiary and the victim of the
tyrannical father just like everyone is
the beneficiary and the victim of mother
nature and of themselves
and so you lock horns with out and
straighten it out one way or another and
you don't move it forward to the next
generation so and maybe you detach it a
bit from your parents too because god
only knows what combination of
catastrophes culminated in their
particular forms of pathology so good
enough
[Applause]